oh mein gott mein alter ja da könnte ich
so einen break machen dass sich die so
richtig einpacken und dann sieht sie
diese und denkt sogar geil alter die
schuhe man danke war alter leute ich
weiß der hintergrund ist extrem hässlich
ich gebe mein bestes ich ein paar kerzen
besorgten zu und wird beachtet auch
nicht auf die bettdecke ist mir noch
etwas unangenehm
[Musik]
er wird an hier
naja aber es kann niemand sagen ich
hätte mir keine mühe gegeben kamera und
ein bisschen schief was geht ab und
damit herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
um das ganze hier vielleicht mal kurz zu
erklären ich bin jetzt über weihnachten
natürlich auch mit meinen eltern also
wieder zurück in meinem alten
kinderzimmer
ich wollte eigentlich wirklich der
richter könnte da so dranhängen das
problem ist die war irgendwie kaputt die
die wehr zu haben wir am sonntag das
heißt ich kann keine kaufen aber jetzt
habe ich also ein paar kerzen angezündet
so bisschen auf weihnachten also ich
hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse über
diesen geistlichen hintergrund ich kann
halt nichts machen
trotzdem gibt es heute ein video auf
dass nämlich eigentlich sehr freue weil
wir haben wieder eine menge sachen oder
das haben sich familiäre menge sachen
angestaut die ich noch gar nicht
ausgepackt habe ich muss sagen ich bin
mir noch gar nicht so sicher wie ich
dieses video am ende nennen weil an sich
ist ja schon wieder eine mystery boxe
ich habe keinen plan was dir drin und
ihr wisst es ja ich bestell andauernd
irgendwo und manchmal kommen auch sachen
zu spät an und dann liegen ja irgendwie
über rum
[Musik]
ja ach mein ladekabel
vielleicht seid also wir haben praktisch
wieder so eine art mystery box aus china
so könnte man das nennen ja das ist
glaube ich ein guter video titel de
sehen können so damit größte und paketen
einmal das und das und die legt ja schon
zur seite weil man plötzlich tun dass
man wieder hier in die box und jetzt
sehe ich einfach eins nach dem anderen
raus packt das aus und wenn ich dann
weiß was es ist kann ich euch
gegebenenfalls auch sagen wo ich hiermit
fangen wir mal leute ich hab ja vor
einer woche dieses video gemacht die
verschwitzten airport cases aus der
ganzen welt also ich habe im internet
irgendwelche airport textes gekauft also
ein bisschen ähnlichkeit ist da würde
ich mal sagen also das ist zu heftigen
pro geil oder wir haben hier einfach
einen krieg hat und ich glaube diese
hier ist halt ein bisschen verspätet
angekommen
bisher war auch so was machst du da habe
ich jetzt das denken sich wahrscheinlich
schon wieder annähen ich schon wieder
jetzt geht's wieder mit erfolglos
versprochen in zukunft wird das weniger
so jetzt habe ich mir geholt compass
direct eigentlich ganz gut sagt ja nicht
schlecht komme jetzt hat man hier so
sieht auf jeden fall ganz schick aus ich
glaube ich weiß wo ich her also falls es
wegen wir haben will
ich hatte euch gerne dinge in die
beschreibung das problem bei dem einen
oder anderen case ist dass man das nicht
also hier geht es eigentlich ganz gut
dass man das halt nicht komplett auf
machen kann weil sich das halt hier
praktisch in die quere kommen kann man
ja eigentlich verstehen oder naja gut
ist auch egal und eine extrem trasse
nachricht habe glaubt für euch
[Musik]
ich glaube das hier ist schon mal ein
pulli oder so und es war wollte ich euch
noch sagen richtig gute nachrichten das
teuerste produkt ist erst dann bei mir
in köln angekommen also der postbote
wollte halt zu stellen ging nicht weil
war keiner da jetzt über weihnachten bei
meinen eltern und kannst nicht abholen
eigentlich erst ratifizieren bestellt
aber es ist auf jeden fall ein getroffen
und ich denke am 28 29
dezember geht es dann damit los dass ich
das halt auspacken kann also merkt euch
das abonniert den kanal weil wir sind
fast bald eine million und dann werden
die videos wir schon auch cool
ja ja ja so heißt das ist dass qualität
vor krass ist das schlimm das kann man
vorher gar nicht anfassen also die
bestellung hiervon liegt wirklich schon
ziemlich weit zurück ich musste mich
sagen ich wollte irgendwann mal testen
sie ob reese ich kenne das von facebook
werbeanzeigen da sieht man die übelsten
leisten die für 15 euro
und ich glaube darüber habe ich so was
mal gekauft aber das ist wirklich
grausam also das ist nicht mal drei euro
wert alter werden trägt denn so was
guck mal das wie das auch geschnitten
ist dass kaufleute das war so klar dass
man alter ich könnte mir nicht ohne
probleme
aufreißen er zwar nicht mehr
theoretischen die jacke raus machen egal
lassen wir mal an vielleicht sieht es
auch der kamera ganz gut aus bisschen
neidisch so ne yo ich sehe mich gerade
beim fenster da könnte schon ganz cool
kommen ich glaube damit gehe ich gleich
bei uns hier auf dem weihnachtsmarkt ok
riecht aber einen ganz gut das ist lebt
los kann gut sein dass ich den mal
irgendwann mal meinen kostenlosen
produkten bestellt hat würde ich mir
jetzt nicht unbedingt auftragen kann ja
sein dass irgendwelche ausschlag
hervorruft segen wie langweilig komme
mir die aktion ist
moment mal eine schlafmaske also das ist
gut das kann nicht wirklich sehr sehr
gut gebrauchen erster ihr müsst dann
mein gesicht nicht ganz so und zweitens
hatte ich eine die ich aber verloren hat
und im flugzeug oder so ist sowas
wirklich geil oder ich bin auch so
jemand ich hasse das wenn morgen zu gast
viel licht in deine augen kommt versteht
ihr da kann auch mal ganz geil sein aber
wenn man so schlafen will dann nervt
mich das und dafür ist eine schlafmaske
aus china natürlich genau das richtige
so hatte ich die gerade die ganze zeit
voll stur auf malta das ist wirklich
krank
vor allem jetzt ist glaube ich gerade
ein neuer star wars rausgekommen ich
muss sagen ich bin absolut kein star
wars fan das unterhält mich irgendwie
nicht so aber zurück zu den airport
cases wir haben wir wirklich eine star
wars oder star wars oder sonst dass wir
das irgendwie peinlich wenn es nicht
star wars wäre und die ist wirklich von
der qualität her wales nice ich weiß
nicht mehr was ich dafür bezahlt habe
ich würde man denken so sieben euro oder
so ich habe mir das video schon gedreht
da waren wirklich ultra lustige dabei
entdeckt dass auf jeden fall ab die
waren von der qualität ja aber nicht die
waren in ordnung auf jeden fall die
waren aber nicht so gut wie diese hier
und hier immer noch gar nicht das
problem dass man das nicht ganz
entspannt aufklappen kann also das ist
bis jetzt die beste also von der
qualität her wenn ich jetzt wirklich
star wars fan wäre wäre es
wahrscheinlich auch generell die beste
ich glaube da weiß ich sogar bricht ihr
hatte ich euch sehr gerne den link in
die video beschreibung und können sogar
stehen alter ich bin der dümmste ich bin
so dumm das ist ein auto
ich dachte das wäre diese star wars
maske das sieht aus wie eine maske
das ist natürlich ein auto hat das jetzt
überhaupt irgendwas mit star wars zu tun
an die star wars für entschuldigung das
wusste es nicht
oh mein gott ich habe so eine gute idee
ich weiß dass meine freundin diese
videos ähnlich schaut also bitte sagt es
ihr und nicht aber das sind ja sowieso
alexander mcqueen fakes und die wünscht
sich schon immer diese schuhe und ich
habe überlegt ihr die vielleicht zu
weihnachten zu kaufen mache ich denke
ich nicht weil ich habt ihr jetzt
eigentlich schon da könnte ich so ein
projekt machen dass ich dir so richtig
einpacken und dann sieht sie diese und
denkst du nur geil hatte die schule
meinen dackel und dann stellt sich
heraus dass sie fähig sind leute wenn
ihr darauf bock habt dann gibt man
finden dann nach oben dann mache ich das
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht mein haus
geschenk für sie also eigentlich erst
gar kein geschenk sondern einfach nur
lustig fürs video ach und dann die die
jetzt fragen deswegen habe ich die
ursprünglich eigentlich auch bestellt
weil ich glaube die haben so 30 euro
gekostet oder so bin von der qualität
eigentlich auch ganz gut also da hatte
ich schon schlechtere schuhe weiter was
ist das sind hier habe ich das jetzt
schon ich habe schon kaputt gemacht kann
man hier das abgebrochen
ja super schaut heute das ist so fürs
bad da kann man so trugen dranhängen
oder so zahnpasta tuben problem ist nur
der transport hat dieses dingen
beschädigt und es ist nicht mehr
verwendbar
warum ich bestellt weiß ich schon gar
nicht mehr
aber es hat die kaputt mein gott mein
alter eigentlich kann ich dieses video
schon die verrücktesten airportpark 2
nennt wir haben hier eine fast in die
könnte ich eigentlich mein bruder
schenken
berlin berlin er ist nämlich ein fan von
diesem auto aber eben die frage ich mich
wann ich die bestellt habe komme aber
sieht auf jeden fall übelsten eis aus
alter das mainfeld bis jetzt ich habe
dir auf jeden fall schon mal gesehen
kann man auch gut auf machen also wenn
ihr ein fan von diesem auto seit dem
airport hat save die hülle nissan gt-r
ohne scheiß ich glaube ich lass das ist
erst mal so eine sache habe ich glaube
noch gewählt habe ich noch
muss das hier hab ich noch okay das
irgendwie auch ein bisschen lasch
sonneberger anhänger na ja ich würde
sagen also diese schuhe finde ich ganz
nice auch wenn es natürlich halbwegs
sind sollte man nicht so ganz
unterstützen aber trotzdem freue ich
mich auf den pranken falls es zustande
kommt und diese höhen
die sind am leichtesten also vor allem
die hier und die geld mehr habe ich
leider nicht jetzt sind irgendwie alle
sachen die bei uns herum flogen auch
schon wieder aufgebraucht aber ich bin
mir sicher wir können das so in ein zwei
drei monaten auf jeden fall noch mal
machen abonniert alle fleißig den kanal
dann schaffen wir vielleicht dieses jahr
die million wird eng aber können ja noch
theoretisch klappen und wir sehen uns
dann morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt es ein
neues video hat ich muss morgen noch
weihnachtsgeschenke räume ich hoffe ich
schaffe das alles aber es wird schon
leuchtet haut rein und falls
irgendwelche ideen habt was ich noch im
hintergrund hängen kann jetzt die
nächsten fünf videos weil die muss ich
alle hier drin dann lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen haut rein instagram
alex wie zschau